tout
[Musique]
l'histoire commence dans un décor de
rêve à quelques kilomètres au nord
d'ajaccio
voici félix et ange son frère jumeau
ils ont 54 ans et sont issu d'une grande
famille corse les biancamaria installés
depuis des générations dans ce petit
coin de paradis
le golfe de lava c'est mon secteur
j'avais ma famille qui habitait là mes
grands parents
donc vous allez découvrir la plage de
l'offre commence à être très connu de
genre il ya encore quelques années la
plupart de ces terrains appartenaient à
leurs familles un patrimoine qui leur a
permis de ne jamais travailler
c'est là qu'ils ont passé leur jeunesse
et et chaque dimanche ils recevaient
leurs amis sur cette petite plage pour
une dégustation d'oursins on appelle ça
une oursinades face au sida y avait je
pars 50 60 personnes qui montaient alors
vin blanc ou ça tous les week à cela
fait bon et à force de faire des sources
en ici bas on a fêté le coin et on avait
décidé d'aller plus loin
c'était tilly a 25 ans et ce genre là on
allant à la pêche
ils vont trouver beaucoup mieux que des
fruits de mer l'un des plus beaux
trésors jamais découvert le trésor de
lava qui se cachait depuis des siècles
juste derrière cette pointe rocheuse
[Musique]
le lendemain matin felix accepte de nous
y conduire grâce au bateau de l'un de
ses amis
nous atteignons rapidement cette petite
crique accessible uniquement par la mer
à l'époque de la découverte félix à 28
ans évidemment un quart de siècle plus
tard il a un peu perdu la main la combi
tu t'assures tu va revivre dans l'eau
nous sommes le 6 septembre 1985
ce matin-là félix plonge avec marc un
ami aujourd'hui décédé
comme d'habitude les deux hommes se
laissent glisser le long des rochers à
la recherche des oursins mais cette fois
c'est un éclat doré qui attire
l'attention de marque
qu'est ce qui te presque en parfait état
elle était à moitié progression' et donc
il a ramassé ça sans savoir ce que
c'était un peu plus loin une autre pièce
puis une troisième très vite félix se
renseigne sur leur valeur et surprise
elles valent des milliers d'euros elle
date de l' empire romain il y à 1700 ans
certaines sont totalement inconnus comme
celle ci qui porte le visage de
l'empereur gallien à l'époque elle vaut
à elle seule 50 mille euros alors félix
son frère et son amie marques vont
plonger dans cette crique pendant près
d'un an
étonnamment alors qu'il n'ya ici aucune
épave de navire
ils trouvent des centaines de pièces
cachées sous les rochers vous en ai
trouvé combien au total on va parfois
six ans aussi
chaque putschistes et au fond de court
en sachant ce que ça va être quoi julien
je crois trois points de mieux que
l'auto beaucoup plus que l'on tourne
beaucoup mieux que le loto en effet
aujourd'hui le trésor de lava c'est plus
de 25 millions d'euros la fortune de
félix et de ses proches semblent faites
mais il ya tout de même un petit
problème la loi
en france un trésor trouvé en mer
appartient à l'état félix aurait donc dû
le remettre aux autorités une loi que
beaucoup ont du mal à comprendre qu'il
suffit de faire le tour du marché pour
s'en rendre compte
je ne vois pas pourquoi on va prendre
tout ce que vous avez trouvé un
alors que c'est vous qui le trouvait
qu'est ce que vous en faites vous
trouverez un trésor et j'en garderai un
tout petit peu un tout petit peu
beaucoup non non non j'ai durée vraiment
les gens qui fuient
ah oui mais tu ne déclare pas à non
déclarés la loi prévoit une récompense
jusqu'à 30000 euros pour celui qui
découvre un trésor sous marin et le
remet à l'état mais félix lui décide de
garder ses pièces et de les vendre un
délit pour lequel il risque jusqu'à deux
ans de prison
[Musique]
il prend l'avion et se rend à paris près
de la place de la bourse
dans la rue de richelieu celle des
numismates ses boutiques où l'on vend
des pièces de collection
alors que c'est interdit certains
acceptent de lui acheter son trésor et
la vente ne va pas se faire en une fois
félix vient au fur et à mesure qu'il
trouve des pièces cela va durer un an
cette période incroyable de sa vie il la
raconte à eric fraticelli cet acteur et
humoriste corse qui écrit un film sur
son histoire
les deux hommes se voient régulièrement
pour mettre au point un scénario comme
tu trouvais ces pièces ont monté
directement à paris devant tient pas car
derrière tu veux monter en avion oui
bien sûr et quand ces pièces qui les
avait sur toi sur moi je ne faisais pas
prendre à l'aéroport ce n'est pas
pendant tu les as valet comme les
passeurs de drogue les xavier l'argent à
vous faisait la fête
ah ouais quand on voit votre big me
restera ses sorties avec beaucoup d'amis
parce qu'à cette époque là j'ai beaucoup
d'amis des voitures des palaces des
montres de marque pendant quatre ans
félix fréquentent les plus grands
palaces il flambe des milliers d'euros
dans les casinos et achètent des
dizaines de voitures comme ce tout
terrain de luxe où ce modèle de
collection
pendant ces quatre ans vous avez dépensé
combien
quand vous dépensez 59,50 euros par
semaine écoutez penser ça pendant deux
ou trois ans faites le compte
cinquante mille euros par semaine une
somme colossale
on se croirait déjà dans un film ce qui
m'intéresse dans cette histoire c'est le
côté fièvre de l'or il était pris dans
une dans un tourbillon voilà on se
blesse on trouve des pièces au monde
ça va durer à l'infini et on dépense et
on vit quoi sans calcul
pourquoi on s'est connus que maintenant
donc c'est dommage ça pas non non rien
donc tout cet argent
félix ne le déclare pas aux impôts il a
de la chance il n'est pas repéré par le
fisc mais les ennuis commencent en
novembre 1986 quand ce numismate com est
une grosse erreur
il organise une vente aux enchères
publiques des pièces d'or du trésor de
lava
le problème c'est que l'événement fait
la une de ce journal et attire
l'attention des autorités
l'homme est condamné tout comme félix
son frère et son ami marc 18 mois de
prison avec sursis et 15000 euros
damende aujourd'hui ce numismate est
décédé sa fille a repris son commerce
mais elle n'a pas souhaité nous
rencontrer
la sphère lui reste en travers de la
gorge au cours de l' enquête
soixante dix sept pièces d'or sont
saisis et la sphère aurait pu s'arrêter
là mais l'état n'a pas récupéré la
totalité du trésor alors où est passé le
reste
à l'époque les autorités compétentes ne
s'en préoccupe pas vraiment pour s'en
apercevoir il suffit de se rendre ici au
cabinet des médailles de la bibliothèque
nationale michel amadry le patron des
lieux conserve dans ses coffres
les pièces du trésor de lava saisie par
l'état aujourd'hui elles valent une
petite fortune
une pièce comme le multiple de galien
cette pièce s'est vendu un peu plus de
cinq cent mille euros
et quant aux canto quintillan n'a pour
le moment on en a répertorié 18 ans tour
chacun peut valoir trente quarante
cinquante mille euros
mais ces pièces hors de prix
l'état n'en a donc récupéré que 77 alors
que félix dit en avoir trouvé six ans
très tranquillement ce fonctionnaire du
ministère de la culture nous apprend
qu'il voit régulièrement passer des
autres dans les ventes aux enchères un
peu partout dans le monde
quand on voit dans une vente qui a eu
lieu en 2002 un exemplaire du multiple
de galien donc le troisième exemplaire
voilà on sait que ça vient du trésor de
corse va du trésor de là bas ça peut pas
venir d'ailleurs depuis le procès
personne n'a cherché à récupérer ces
pièces
pas même michel amadry qui a lui-même
assisté à une vente sans intervenir
j'assiste à laventie le rappelle se sont
rendus à très très beaux prix qui est
chargé d'alerter par exemple quand on
voit une pièce qu'ils vont à l'étranger
attapeu c'est un peu nous effectivement
qui alerte on quand on voit des choses
anormales qui ce qui se passe et là vous
avez alerté par exemple dans ce cas là
non là honnêtement non mais sinon je
n'allais pas rester là mais je n'avais
pas alerté non plus il a fallu alerté
effectuant tous les tous les deux mois
ou tous les trois mois
bref à l'époque la surveillance n'est
pas des plus pointilleuse et pendant une
vingtaine d'années
plus personne ne s'intéresse au trésor
de lava
félix lui retrouve sa vie d'avant en
corse finie la flambée les palaces s'est
à nouveau dit il l'argent de sa famille
qui le fait vivre
mais il y a quelques mois un homme
décide de remettre son nez dans cette
enquête corse
il s'appelle michel lourd il est
archéologue et lui aussi fonctionnaire
du ministère de la culture mais du genre
tenace et ce qui le met en colère ce
sont ces particuliers qui conserve des
trésors sous marins dans ce hangar près
de marseille des centaines d'objets
saisis par la justice
vasile on va peut-être prendre celle là
selon lui leur place est au musée comme
ces amphores qui partent aujourd'hui il
trouve normal qu'un trésor sous-marin
appartiennent à l'état quelle que soit
sa valeur
aujourd'hui on apprend qu un
porte-conteneurs qu'un super temps caire
vient de se briser en mer vers qui se
retourne le public il se retourne bien
vers les tares donc pourquoi est-ce que
lorsque c'est un incident est super
temps qu'est rentrerez normal que l'état
soit obligée d'intervenir par contre si
c'est un objet qui a une certaine valeur
marchande alors là on dirait un ballon
l'état s'est produit c'est à moi pour
michel lourd la sphère de la vanne avait
pas livré tous ses secrets
et ce qui lui a mis la puce à l'oreille
c'est ce dessin récupérés par les
enquêteurs à l'époque du procès celui
d'un plat en or que félix aurait trouvé
en même temps que les pièces j'avais
dans l'esprit depuis très longtemps que
cette enquête au fond de 86
et puis le procès etc tout ça n'était
pas une affaire bien fini parce que ce
plat nous avait échappé
michel lourd persuade un juge de relance
l enquête
plusieurs personnes sont placées sur
écoute et la faire connaître un
rebondissement inattendu
[Musique]
à
gare de roissy près de paris au mois
d'octobre dernier
felix est arrêté alors qu'il rentre de
bruxelles une dizaine de policiers
l'interpellent dans le train et dans sa
valise il découvre le fameux plat en or
resté introuvable pendant 25 ans au
moins qui recouvre en fait j'étais sur
mon fauteuil
j'étais menotté en masse orchestrale et
puis on m'a signifié mon ma garde à vue
je me suis dit ah vous suit en fait que
c'était trop tard felix est accusé
d'avoir voulu revendre ce plat à
l'étranger pour la deuxième fois de sa
vie il est mise en examen pour
détournement des pav maritime
en fait on reproche d'abord sorti mais
également un objet
appartements soit six ans entre
guillemets habitants c'est l'histoire
qui se répète 25 ans plus tard après sa
garde à vue
félix et relâché et aujourd'hui le plat
en or du trésor de lava c'est michel
lourds qui l'a récupéré
il le garde dans cet entrepôt quelque
part en france
l'endroit est tenu secret c'est la
première fois qu'une caméra est autorisé
à franchir ses portes
l'objet tant convoité et conservé dans
cet impressionnant coffre-fort le pl10
de lave à la robin du 3ème siècle après
jésus-christ les estimations tournent
entre un million et demi d'euros et
peut-être 25 millions pour ses cases
inestimable ça vous fait quoi d'avoir ce
cadre est une vraie satisfaction d'abord
parce que c'était depuis 25 ans était
une source d'interrogation permanent
deux ans d où il était passé ce qui
donne à ce plat une telle valeur
c'est sa rareté il n'y a pas d'autres
exemplaires datant de cette époque les
meilleurs experts sont tous formelle
voilà on attend de toi que tu nous lis
tout sur lui sa vie son oeuvre
c'est vraiment impressionnant pour moi
c'était mme x unique parce qu'il est
vraiment extrêmement lourd pour son
volume
ce plat d'un kilo est sans doute la
pièce maîtresse du trésor de lava et à
cause de lui félix à de nouveaux ennuis
son procès aura lieu dans quelques mois
il risque une forte amende jusqu'à 400
mille euros pour recel et il affirme ne
plus avoir d'argent
il nous accueille chez son frère dans ce
petit appartement un décor qui tranche
avec la grande vie qui l'ont mené on
imagine que quelqu'un qui trouvent un
trésor il est très riche
et c'est seulement gérer ça revenu
minimum 400 euros par mois vous n'avez
plus rien du trésor les deux frères sont
formels ils ont depuis longtemps flambée
l'argent du trésor pour vivre ils ont
même été obligés de vendre une partie du
patrimoine familial
félix la firme il n'est plus riches en
fait riche oui si vous voulez pas les
pots ce qu'on a dépensé énormément
d'argent mais si vous voulez bon à
l'heure actuelle non si j'avais été
riche et si j'avais encore des pièces
j'aurais pas vendu mon terrain j'ai
vendu on a vendu peut-être presque 40
hectares à l'entendre félix aurait
beaucoup de mal à payer une forte amende
et surtout il se dit victime d'une
injustice
selon lui ce plat qui vaut plusieurs
millions d'euros lui appartient de plein
droit
il affirme qu'il ne l'a pas trouvée dans
l'eau comme les pièces mais sur terre
sous ce rocher marie siens de faire
basculer dessous c'est bien il y avait
un énorme trou avec avec le plateau avec
ses fameux plateau et quelques pièces à
l'intérieur
donc pour vous ce plat il était sur
terre a été sur terre ou un détail qui
change tout car curieusement la loi
n'est pas la même pour un trésor trouvé
sur terre dans ce cas il n'appartient
pas à l'état mais à celui qui l'a trouvé
et au propriétaire du terrain avec
antoine sollacaro son avocat félix veut
prouver ce qu'il avance
et pour ça les deux hommes ont un
argument d'autres pièces du trésor
aurait justement été trouvé sur terre au
même endroit se réfère aux chiffres
cette découverte remonte au siècle
dernier et elle est racontée dans ce
livre écrit par un grand oncle de félix
des ouvriers italiens ont disparu au
cours de la nuit en abandonnant ce
chantier régeard cassés de l'époque
romaine de pièces en or fut retrouvé
lendemain d'inter muet le trésor de
l'avs
c'est un trésor qui pour nous a très
certainement une origine terrestre sur
les cartes des archives départementales
félix et son avocat recherche l'endroit
précis de cette découverte
elle aurait eu lieu pas loin de la
maison sur l'ancienne propriété de félix
ils vont tenter de faire admettre à la
justice que le plat était cachée sur
terre
c'est peut-être un éboulement qui l'a
fait tomber sur la plage il ya
d'ailleurs à cet endroit là des éboulis
donc c'est le fait de l'érosion de la
mer sur le rivage
félix affûte ses arguments mais face à
lui au procès il aura une partie civile
coriace michel lourd et lui affirme que
l'objet a été trouvé dans l'eau il
s'appuie sur un autre livre celui de
félix lui même où il raconte la
découverte du plat je colle l'objet
contre mon ventre et le tiens de ma main
gauche afin de pouvoir récupérer ma
lampe puis j'agite ma palme droite
pourrait bien dans l'eau je perds mon
masque et bois une bonne rasade d'eau de
mer moi je vous dis que ce trésor était
un trésor sous marin et qu'il restera
dans les collections publiques ça j'en
ai une certitude absolue
selon felix ce livre a été romancés pour
rendre l'histoire plus passionnantes
encore c'est maintenant à la justice de
trancher
les scientifiques eux doivent encore
percé un autre mystère comment lors des
romains a pu s'échouer dans ce golfe il
y à 1700 en transformant l'île de beauté
en île aux trésors
[Musique]